vous le savez vraiment vous nous donniez
des bonnes nouvelles il faut du rouge ma
chance je veux dire seulement que je
sais très content et le meilleur jour de
ma vie que j'ai vu monsieur jean-pierre
et madame nathalie 22 jennifer la lionne
pas les bons soirs à nathalie pourtant
jambières vous avez juste un petit
message que vous adressez je trouve que
vous format très très beau couple voilà
vous respirez l'amour c'est aujourd'hui
on devrait tous inspirés de boue
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vrai que ce jour là on était
tellement bien que tpm paix avait
continué enfin on va progresser avec
continuer dans tpm pays regardez
j'ai toujours voulu chanter d'amis j'ai
vraiment eu des vibrations et m me
normand sur celle là donc a pas de
raison
série il n'y a pas de raison
jean-pierre à j'ai toujours aimé
pressentiment sont toujours beaux jours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en
fait d'accord volontaire qui nous détend
bien si le chambrent un peu comme
[Musique]
ouais
c'est corinne qui était reparti avec
50000 euros corrige empire toujours le
bon mot je vraiment quand on le revoilà
les manifs on l aime vraiment qu'est ce
qu'on aime qu est ce qu on aime notre
jean pierre et et c'est vrai que je vous
parlais il ya un instant c'est vrai que
ça il venait me voir même sur france 4
il avait fait un jt en rap ont regardé
c'était une des premières de touche pas
à mon poste vous allez revoir on avait
des sacrés testa seul quand même enfin
vient n'est pas beaucoup d'ailleurs qui
étaient là parce que l'équipe a
complètement changé oui et oui c'est
vrai c'est fou il n'avait aucun ici qui
est témoin sur l'essence kahn n'en reste
qu'au bout
alors ça commence par wesh les bâtards
ça va
tranquille ou quoi alors cet hiver avec
des temps de ce que mme pierrot 64 pages
qui crèche à alençon et qui kiffent plus
raquer c'est
possible edf je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire
commencer trop abusé comment ils l'ont
remarqué c'est sale bâtard
[Rires]
jeter la bande annonce il nous avait
fait la bande-annonce de thé pmp
jean pierre pernaut qu'on aime dans un
instant doha jean pierre foucault
d'ailleurs un qui intervient en fait
style mon ami jean-pierre je le disais
tout à l'heure et trois légendes en
télévision michel drucker jean-pierre
foucault jean pierre pernaut il y en a
une qui nous a quittés aujourd'hui et on
est extrêmement triste de sa disparition
il ya sa fille lou qui est incroyable
aussi qui veut faire du journalisme au
sénat qui est déjà dedans qui a laissé
un petit message sur site toc pour son
papa real
merci à tous pour votre amour on reste
en famille pour le moment profitez de
vos proches et dites leur que vous les
aimez c'est vrai que toute la famille on
livre on les voyait très souvent parce
qu'on les ait mis énormément
gilles joues sont très très émue la
d'avoir revu les images de deux empires
un trait chercher chez bouleversé puis
quand je le vois dire t'as une chance
sur deux c'est tout lui quand il dit ça
dans soit laissé à nathalie qui
effectivement est là là le fluide et
comme ça et lui lui dit tu as une chance
sur deux c'est tout le coup que c'est sa
spontanéité c'est ouais je suis je suis
vraiment bouleversé
je suis super émue et je pense vraiment
très très fort à à nathalie et vous
je laime énorme m alors il nous avait
révélé une fois une passion secrète ans
dans tpm pays regardez la passion
secrète nos vampires perdront une
passion pour la choucroute alors j'adore
parce que ma ferme et alsaciennes donc
la chance déjà à la maison et puis vous
la connaissez bien et elle vous fait
elle vient ici votre nom
et à les coiffer en choucroute
tout simplement